[Music]
thank you welcome to wisdom for life
where we sift through philosophy find
practical advice that you can use in
your everyday life hi I'm Dan and today
I'm with my co-host Dr Greg Seth and
we're talking about answers to a
question and the question is what is
public philosophy and as it turns out
there's a lot of ins and outs to this if
you think that you know the answer
already you might be a little bit
surprised as we go through some of the
responses that other people have given
or proposed as
how we ought to be understanding and
doing public philosophy and before we
actually kick this off I I want to point
out that we're doing it right here this
is a public philosophy show so at least
you know you've got some exposure to it
and Dan and I have both been doing
public philosophy sometimes without
calling it that or realizing it for a
number of years and that's actually how
we got to know each other in the first
place I mean maybe we should tell a
little bit about that story at the top
of this show
you know just so listeners have some
idea about how this sort of thing works
so yeah I guess Greg was already running
the Milwaukee stoic Fellowship
um and I had moved back into Milwaukee
after I was out in
um California and I had met some other
Stokes out there and
um yeah it was a monthly meeting we were
reading through I believe the
um letters from A stoic or you know
seneca's letters or moral letters yeah
that sounds serious yeah yeah
um and um after we were doing that for I
don't know was it over a year before I
proposed doing something more together
yeah I remember actually we were doing
that at the Shorewood Public Library
which is where we were meeting and we
sat in my car I think it must have been
like cold like it was yeah it was cool
it was uh late fall yeah there you go so
that's why we were in the car and then I
I you did bring it up you were like I
was thinking about
and I don't know it was exactly a radio
show I think we were talking about doing
a podcast maybe right uh no actually my
first thought was hey do you want to do
um something like Stoke Camp oh right
yeah we should mention what that is so
there there are other stoic camps like
in Wyoming and Rome and New York and and
so people get together for like I think
like a weekend or a week and they
there's somebody who's well versed in it
and they lead people through Reading and
discussion and practices and there's
usually some perks like you're in Rome
so you get to see some cool statues or
you're in Wyoming so you got you know
beautiful camping surroundings I don't
know what they do in New York but I'm
sure it's something
Upstate there's some really pretty land
up in Upstate New York yeah so there
there you go so so we we're chatting
about that and then I brought up the
fact that
um the station manager at the time had
been suggesting that I should do a show
and I was like well maybe we should do a
show maybe that would be a cool thing to
do
and that's how we stumbled into this and
so you know we're doing public
philosophy here and I I will also
mention that a lot of what we're going
to talk about today is essentially
lifted it's not plagiarism because I'm
the I'm the person who actually did the
presentation so I'm not lifting it out
of somebody else's stuff but I I did a
presentation at the Wisconsin
philosophical it's either Association or
society that met here in the spring
about public philosophy and most of the
people there are not public philosophers
but they were very interested in the
idea and so this is a chance for me to
like shoot out some ideas and proposals
and problems and then Dan I'll think of
it like a tennis match Dan lobs it back
across the net with his own
contributions and uh maybe we'll you
know sometimes knock the ball over the
fence or
muffin or whatever right but um there's
there's a lot to this this topic and so
it's an opportunity to think about what
we're already
engaged in doing and maybe how we can do
it better
yeah and so
um yeah we do this you know every other
week it used to be weekly at one point
in time
um and uh we try to engage with uh
things as the topic or the top of the
show always says that we're trying to
deal with philosophy that you can use in
your everyday life and so we're trying
to bring these Concepts and make them
more accessible and applicable
application is an important part of it
and it's it's you know for a general
audience so we try as best as we can I
think sometimes we forget to but you
know if we use a term that's not an
ordinary English language term we try to
give you some sense of what it means or
direct you towards where you could find
it you know so so this this is I mean
I'm not going to say it's doing exactly
it's not like providing a comprehensive
philosophical education on the radio
waves or anything like that we don't
have we're not that pretentious but
um you you know you should be able to
learn something from listening to this
show
yeah I guess you if you want there's
like there are podcasts that try to do
that like that's true yeah you know
there's what is it the um history of
velocity without anything else that is a
great one and and that's a great example
of public philosophy it's uh it's all
academic philosophers and
they're talking about some pretty
complex topics
and they try to do exactly what the
title says they're trying to go through
the entire history of philosophy without
leaving anybody out which is a cool idea
right because oftentimes we summarize
we're jumping over vast periods of time
and we leave out important uh thinkers
and they're they're trying to do it not
just in terms of like chronology but
also
um space and
cultures so they've got a lot of stuff
on sub-Saharan African philosophy and
Indian philosophy I think they've gotten
to Chinese philosophy it's been a while
since yeah they have whole different
um sections so like they went through
all Western philosophy and then they
went through all of uh what
East Asian philosophy and then I maybe
the Indian subcontinent and I also have
one on African philosophy and because
those are the the main areas of um
conversation I guess you could at some
point there's also I don't know where it
was lumped in but like there's lots in
the
um Middle East especially in like the
the Golden Age of Islam going on down
there that's I mean this is a bit of a
side point but when we're tired people
will often like contrast Western versus
Eastern philosophy and I'm always like
yeah Eastern doesn't really work we
don't want to be
accidentalists about this and lump
everybody into one big package because
what's going on in the Indian
subcontinent is very very different than
what's happening in East Asia and each
of them is just so so vast right we
don't want to like say oh there's this
essence of easternism or something and
then you know what about Africa and what
about Native American uh philosophies
and things like that but the Islamic
world the Islamic civilizations really
present a classificatory problem because
you know they they fed into uh what we
typically call Western philosophy you
know Thomas Aquinas for example in the
Middle Ages is citing
I haven't seen and and you know avaros
and and these other people and and as
they got more and more of these thinkers
available to them they they would engage
with them
so you know there's that going on but it
but it is also its own interesting
cultural world that is formed by the
um influence of Islamic civilization and
the different uh well the the other
groups that they're encountering so
yeah that that one presents some
problems and I will actually give a
shout out there's a really cool thing
called the Aquinas and the Arabs project
that is partially situated at Marquette
University just down the road uh and
that's because one of the professors at
Marquette Richard Taylor has played a
really important role in that so
Marquette is one of the few places where
if you're doing history of philosophy
there's a good chance you might actually
be studying Arabic as opposed to just
Latin or Greek or pick whatever right
you're looking at or any like languages
in sub-Saharan Africa
yeah yeah okay yeah
um so uh what what are some
um you know examples yeah how how do we
Define this term well
because we've given examples already
yeah you know defining it is something
that people have been really trying to
do and failing at I think
um and the reason
is in large part because there's no
there's no real consensus and I think
it's in part because there can't be
because you typically start thinking
about what is public philosophy because
you're doing it right you you don't like
sit off in the proverbial Ivory Tower
and think to yourself hmm maybe I should
do something for the public one of these
days let's let's do some public
philosophy it's usually more like while
you're already doing it and you found
some people that agree with you that
it's an important thing then maybe you
put together an organization and then
the kind of public philosophy that
you're doing typically becomes the
Paradigm for how you think public
philosophy
ought to be done and we're going to look
at some definitions I think the
definitions are are useful not so much
to
you know circumscribe the topic but to
give us ideas about like what what
people are interested in what public
philosophy could look at
um I do want to say it's oh go ahead
definitely like a a multi-modal thing
that like there's definitely yeah
there's many different ways in which we
can
um do public philosophy and for certain
um goals there's going to be definitely
significantly different ways in which
one can practice that yeah I mean I
think it is important because people
will ask us well what are you actually
doing that we have at least some things
that we can say to them so because you
know the the interested public wants to
be able to wrap its head around stuff
and simply saying well there's no
definition that that's not very
satisfying to them I think
so uh here's a a more concrete example
that I was thinking about on you know
thinking about the Civil Rights Movement
um and how there's a very strong
philosophical underpinning of that yeah
and and one of the most Salient pieces I
can pull out of that is on the letter
from the Birmingham Jail in which MLK is
talking about a very philosophical idea
of the difference between positive peace
and negative peace and how peace in and
of itself does not denote Justice right
right if you're going to have Justice
you must have positive peace and so
because we're on this public philosophy
Forum here I will Define these two
things uh
a negative piece is a piece that is
brought upon by uh force that there is
uh that you are peaceful and working in
society because
um there is always a threat of force
that is going to be coming down on you
um so hey a um slave plantation can be
peaceful
um yeah but be only because there is the
uh man with the whip at the end of the
throw just waiting for you to step out
of line whereas a positive piece is a
um a society in which
everyone wants to they bought into the
society and because they feel like they
are one have Justice within that Society
you know they've bought in and they feel
like they are on getting the things that
they need to live their good lives yeah
and there's the possibility for learning
from each other solidarity and all that
yeah you know the letter from a
Birmingham Birmingham Jail is really a
great example of public philosophy in
one of the senses that we're going to
look at if you read through it you
notice that King himself who you know
was University educated he refers to a
number of earlier philosophers Saint
Augustine Thomas Aquinas
Paul tilik I'm trying to remember who
else he brings up and there's a number
of interesting ideas that are that are
worked out you know he's like talking
about the difference between just and
unjust laws and he introduces like a new
way of thinking about that but one that
incorporates previous ideas it's really
a rich document
I'll say too as a side note when I
taught at Fayetteville State University
which is a historically black University
in North Carolina
um every you know when we get to close
to Martin Luther King Day
there'd be a lot of attention paid to
his stuff and so I'd often get asked by
like history classes to come in and give
a guest lecture unpacking the argument
in the letter from a Birmingham Jail and
there's a very complex robust argument
there that's being made and a lot of
these a lot of these uh college students
first of all they'd never read it
because in a lot of places it's just not
part of the curriculum so they're
they're reading it and they're not sure
what they're what they're supposed to
make of it they know that MLK is a good
guy and you're supposed to have warm
fuzzy feelings towards them and so we
would like spend a whole hour just like
unpacking what's going on in this
section what's going on in this section
and then like seeing people you know
when you look out in the audience and
you see the facial reactions like some
are puzzled and some are like they've
got that I I'm getting it kind of face
and some are smiling and some are
frowning because they're they're not
quite sure what the hell's going on
it's uh it's really quite cool you know
and and to extend you know not only is
this a public document that was trying
to inform the public it is also uh to a
certain extent a on
I want to call it exactly uh call arms
but like a call to action right that
this is the
um the issue that we are dealing with
here currently in our society and it is
fundamentally unjust and thus therefore
um
spur you an action to doing something to
try to write these wrongs that would
have been enumerated in the letter
that's right yeah yeah and it becomes
part of our philosophical Canon
interestingly enough you know if you get
yourself a textbook on what we call
social and political philosophy you'll
usually find the letter from a
Birmingham Jail anthologized in it
unfortunately that's usually the only
thing they've got by King in there but
because he's got a plenty of other good
stuff but
um
the latter stuff that gets totally
subbed under the rug where he's very
much oh yeah yeah I'm thinking in terms
of class not just race yeah yeah yeah
um well let's let's talk about about
definitions so you know we said there
isn't a single definition but there are
plenty of people who've tried to give
definitions so one of the really
commonly referenced one is by this guy
Jack Russell Weinstein who um wrote an
essay what does public philosophy do and
he says okay so public philosophy
denotes the act of professional
philosophers engaging with
non-professionals in a non-academic
setting with the specific goals of
exploring issues philosophically and I
think that's not bad you know I mean
that covers a lot of the grounds of what
we're we're thinking about you know
professional philosophers
um engaging with non-professionals okay
so that's definitely part of what's
going on I think that in a non-academic
setting
maybe that's important but you know it
could still be like an academic
institution like you could do something
on campus and it could still be public
philosophy but you're not doing it in
the classroom itself you know like in in
a accredited
class that runs for 15 weeks uh what do
you think about that one
it's
it's an okay one I guess you know in
general it it feel I feel it but yeah
that's it it's it's very very general it
and it may actually leave some stuff out
so I'm curious to see what you make of
this one this is a another one from
Michael Burrows in supporting public
philosophy two lives and three
strategies he talks about a stipulative
definition we should probably say in a
minute what a stipulative definition is
of public philosophy as a philosophical
practice that engages and collaborates
with stakeholders Beyond The Academy
towards the end of improving our
communities
okay that's I think that's not bad I
like the idea of thinking of things in
terms of stakeholders which is kind of
business ethic ethicsy kind of language
um but it just means people that have
some sort of you know as we say skin in
the game in in the community and that
one focuses more on like what we're
doing in terms of
communities I am a little oh go ahead I
was just gonna say like I like the the
the term actually stakeholders because
it's not only you know people that own a
thing but it's like everyone that that
is interacting within that organization
however wide you want to Define it and
so you know
um you've got a town if you've got like
the the residents and the business
owners and you've got workers and you
have people that work there but don't
live there and people that live there
and don't work there and
um and all these people have a different
desire for the need and the needs that
they need from the organizations in
order to run well so that they can do
whatever they need to do and so it's
just really kind of this
all-encompassing thing and if you're if
you really think strongly about the the
full vastness of the stakeholders you
realize that often you are missing a lot
of people that you would otherwise not
think about because it's not directly
affecting them like monetarily because a
lot especially if you're talking
business you know if it's not hitting
monetarily then it might not even be an
existing thing and so this is trying to
expand that that is actually a really
great Point
um
by thinking in terms of stakeholders we
find the ones that are sort of like the
obvious stakeholders and then we find
the other people who are affected
positively or negatively but perhaps in
terms of other
values or outcomes and who might be at
the risk of having some of the costs of
things pushed off onto them if we're not
careful what they call externalities in
the business
yeah the one thing I I don't like about
this definition
is that
um it it ties public philosophy
to this goal of the end of improving our
communities and I think improving our
communities that's great I'm not
knocking that but I don't think that all
Public public facing philosophy is
necessarily about improving our
communities it could be personal
development you know like what we what
we were doing in the stoic Fellowship we
I mean there is the opportunity to like
go out and do stuff but a lot of it is
like how do I deal with my own anxiety
and you could say well if you do that
then you're going to be less of a jerk
to other people but it's it's more about
the the you or you know I mean sometimes
public philosophy could be us chatting
about literature that we're reading and
it doesn't have any direct social effect
you know we're like what makes a good
book a good book no no there's no
the Aesthetics
um
and you know personal ethics but these
things will will bleed out into our
communities but it's not directly it's
that's a a second order effect instead
of a primary effect yeah and you know uh
we could think of like metaphysics and
philosophy of Technology too as fitting
in with that there's a lot of talk these
days about you know Ai and a whole
variety of you know it's going to kill
us you know no it's going to be our it's
going to be our our uh Helper and savior
and everything in between
um and just trying to figure out well
what the hell's actually going on in a
philosophical way that might be very
helpful but it might not have the end of
like improving our communities it could
maybe we could say that
you know improving our community is one
of many different possible Goods that
could be achieved yeah
what do you what do you think about this
other one by Lucia uh zigoli public
philosophy is best understood as an
activity that aims to promote rational
thinking in anyone it can reach
public philosophy as a catalyst to
thought its goal is not to disclose the
results of the philosophical tradition
or research at least not exclusively and
not primarily its main aim is to
introduce the audience to the
philosophical practice of thinking
critically that is problem
problematization of the given the
critique and Analysis of a question and
a dialectical
confrontation I mean to me that that
starts veering off into a lot of
aspirational jargon you know
philosophers always love to talk about
problem problematization dialectical
stuff critique
um
but I think the the first part of this
is a little bit more Salient to the
public okay whereas the second is
definitely kind of pandering to the
academic oh interesting yeah yes well
which oddly seems to work here if we're
talking about like this this
incorporation of the academic into the
public space
yeah and it helps to answer the question
what the hell are academics actually
good for right
yeah and I mean in a lot of cases the
answer is nothing you know
at least that's yes there are a lot of
people who think that all like
non-sciences are of of zero or or no use
and yeah obviously we will don't think
so that there's a lot of benefit that we
can create from thinking critically
about these things you know I in general
I like the idea of trying to promote
rational thinking yeah um yeah but this
also requires a little bit more research
like how exactly you're defining
rational thinking and you know
right so they don't just become
buzzwords rationality logic
evidence-based with all these these
terms I mean if we are going to be
really critical we have to say what do
you actually mean by that what counts as
evidence what counts as logic yeah
and hopefully you have really good
um understandings of those things and
definitions that you can like okay these
are the criteria that we're defining
these things under and it reminds me of
um watching old original Star Trek and
um
odd
Spock is making these things like it
it's only rational that you know because
X therefore y on and and I'm like did
the writers think this was actually
rational
um or it was it just seemed like there
was some prejudices of the time of the
writing that like yeah a lot of the
things that Spock says are logical or
rational don't turn out to be so when we
put them under scrutiny and you're like
what's wrong with these Vulcans right
right yeah
so why don't we let's let's talk about
another thing so maybe we don't Define
it maybe you know one of the things we
sometimes do in philosophy is we say
okay we can't define something
adequately at least we can distinguish
it into its parts right and maybe we get
an idea about what public philosophy
looks like by doing that so there was
this really famous report at least in
philosophy circles public philosophy
Circles by maeger and fader in 2010
called practicing public philosophy and
it was in the American philosophical
Association Committee on Public
philosophy and they recommended creating
a public philosophy Network which
actually happened and became like a big
mover in the community and so they
um they noted that there were three
positions when you ask philosophers what
is public philosophy that the the people
came up with so one was philosophy
difficult practice as a public good the
other another was public philosophy
having the explicit aim of benefiting
public life and then the third was
public philosophy as liberatory
assisting and empowering those who are
most vulnerable and suffer Injustice and
I mean those are all sound like good
things to pursue and they do seem to be
distinct right I mean you can
try to assist and empower the people who
are most vulnerable I mean letter from
Birmingham jails a prime example of that
um without you know necessarily
promoting philosophical practices of
public good it's not like Martin Luther
King was saying all right everybody
let's uh put our logic thinking caps on
and start training or something like
that and I think you could do the others
as well independently I mean maybe it's
it's nice when you can hit more than one
but does this strike you as enough
enough I guess enough is
say enough
it's um is it perfect probably not are
any of these perfect probably not yeah
that's and maybe that's a bit of a side
note there
um the demand to have like the perfect
definition or classification I I often
have seen this in academic and
non-academic settings
winding up being more of a it's not a
conversation Ender
but it draws the conversation off into
areas that become less and less
productive it's sort of like almost like
a law of diminishing returns as you
steer the conversation into let's let's
make this almost as perfect as we can
you you get less and less done
because you're you're
getting too Stuck In The Weeds mired in
the weeds instead of actually trudging
forward and making progress right yeah
so you know another alternative is uh
from Burrows and Valentine where they
said that public philosophy takes a
number of different forms and they
proposed
um three main functions of it what they
call field philosophy which is you know
like well the philosophy of technology
stuff so you're going to you know think
about Ai and then write a column for I
don't know the New Yorker or the I mean
if they were interested in having it the
shepherd Express or you know the
Milwaukee Journal you write an op-ed
piece so that's that's one thing you're
taking philosophy and then applying it
in a way that you know maybe you can
reach out to
non-academics and then there's popular
philosophy where you're you're actually
um trying to to do Outreach as they call
it to other people and then they also
talk in terms of activist philosophy and
so you know this kind of uh this is kind
of a recurring theme isn't it what it
but what if you're like a philosopher
and you're not so interested in activism
does that mean that you're not as good
of a public philosopher
I don't know I'm I guess it depends on
what your ends are hmm
if you're trying to like as we work with
like the snow Fellowship like to just
improve the individuals that come and
join us
um that's not exactly activists it's not
trying to like make systemic change but
it is trying to make yeah change in the
the individuals
um and you definitely
um there are popular philosophers and
once again grabbing from The Stokes and
like there's uh Ryan holiday who
definitely works in
popularizing public philosophy and
stoicism specifically yeah that's true
um
he might be a little bit too more too on
the popular end where he gets a little
loosey-goosey with yeah
um like you know like I've noticed
sometimes he'll rely on bad translations
of things and then you know he I don't
think he actually reads Greek so like
when it comes to Marcus Aurelius who's
his guy
you know some of the translations are a
little wonky from time to time and so
it's almost like stepping on a bridge
where it's a little rickety and you know
you don't want to like accidentally step
through because you're putting too much
weight on something
um he just runs across the bridge
what how does he Define uh field
philosophy
well
um that's where you're
um teaching about things that are in in
a domain a field right so okay the
philosophy of Technology you know would
be a prime example of something that's
getting a lot of attention lately mainly
because of AI stuff right it's not like
people are right what's what's a fork
how does it work
what what are the employee implications
of this new technology and how it's
going to enter in the world right right
you can take this back all the way down
to like the the luddites and their
argument or their um destroying of the
um weaving looms oh yeah you know I mean
you could study the luddites from a
historical perspective and then you
could also say well wait a second these
people maybe I mean because they had
sophisticated arguments you could like
let's read their arguments and see why
they were smashing machinery and whether
we should do the same thing you know
right
yeah so that's a great example
um
I like this other uh
breakdown that that Lucia zagoli has in
a recent book review that says there's
three possible ways to understand the
relationship between the two poles of
public and philosophy so there's a
different way of parsing it out right
so one of them is activities performed
by professional philosophers to bring
philosophy to non-professionals so it's
like public education so if I go and I
give a talk well I like the talks that I
give at the Frank Weinberg Library where
it's called philosophers in the midst of
history and I'll say okay what was what
was going on with Socrates or Thomas
Aquinas or like the upcoming one will be
David Hume how did how did history
inform them how did they influence
history I'm doing most of the talking
and then the audience will ask some
questions or they'll raise some issues
right but it's mostly me the philosopher
doing a presentation so it's kind of
it's not a completely one-way thing but
it's what would be the word for that
it's primarily on one end one to many
okay yeah that's a good way so then this
other one I think this is really
important the contribute contribution
the public can make to the work of
philosophers and they frame it as an
antidote to epistemic injustices which
is again a jargony philosophy term which
basically just means some people have
been left out of the conversation and
their points of view
their ways of knowing things have been
ignored
I think this is actually great I mean
this is this is what a lot of
um say you know classic feminist
literature was doing if you read Mary
Wollstonecraft who's writing in the 18th
century you know she's basically like a
contemporary of uh say Kant
or Simone de bouvoir with the second sex
doing all these really interesting
analyzes or more recent uh people
they're they're saying hey there's this
whole domain of life that you've not
paid adequate attention to and you'd be
doing better philosophy and understand
things you know in your life better if
you actually paid attention to like
social dynamics or how people are
educated or in the case of Mary
woolstonecraft she even had stuff to say
about like physical education and the
fact that women were being treated as if
they're these delicate flowers at least
you know upper class middle class women
were and then they're not allowed to
develop their their bodies which you
know know has some connections to the
mind so
um yeah I had a
quick aside my um my mom was a very
active athlete
and I guess the uh should be in high
school and like the
late 60s right okay yeah
and
um
to the point where she had a knee injury
about the doctors on thought they they
would they ignored the knee injury
because oh
uh women don't get
athletic injuries oh wow
and so it's not only that they weren't
even offered but it was anathema to even
think that that was a possibility even
at the medical level that's crazy
yeah I mean there's stuff like that even
going on today you know they're they're
still doctors out there who are like
black people don't feel pain the same
way white people do and you're like
where in the hell did you get that idea
and it turns out you know there's like a
long racist history that somehow they
imbibed you know
um but coming back to this so I like
this idea the contribution the public
can make to the work of philosophers now
it's not just the philosopher talking
you know coming down from the mountain
bringing nuggets of wisdom it's other
people saying hey you should actually
think about this uh and you know not
just because it's in your philosophy
books but because this actually matters
you know right I think a lot of
philosophers
um would benefit from being told off
every once in a while by other people
saying you you forgot about this buddy
and you see this with um academics all
the time like they they like come up
with some Theory uh of like why certain
things are not working in society and
they're like okay we're gonna go and do
some field work and they go into
wherever and they just get basically
smacked upside the head you know
figuratively that all their theories are
are based off of like poor uh
presuppositions yeah they have to
totally reorient themselves the reality
of the situation yeah that I think
that's I mean
that's so common it's become a Trope in
TV shows and movies right although it's
usually not done very well because
they're they'll just have like you know
five minutes of interaction and then
they'll have like their light bulb
moment happen when I mean that stuff in
reality it takes years and years right
uh there's a great scene in um the wire
on the about that and uh I've never
actually watched that so is there like
is is there an academic who's coming in
to study these people
um yeah there's uh
every scene a season in the show is is
quite interesting the first season deals
with
um the drug dealers and the the cops
yeah second season digs deep into the
public education system I think the
season three deals with uh the political
system within uh Baltimore and I think
the fourth season on
oh I think
there's one that that's also like the
the longshoremen is a lot what they're
doing and then the last one is doing at
the point right yeah and the last season
is dealing with
um the the newspapers the journalists
and how they oh interacting so the whole
show is really this like uh study of
like how these different systems
interact and influence each other
um over the course of years and and one
of these has you know an academic coming
in it's like okay how can we we save the
the youth from getting sucked into the
um the drug trade in the worst
neighborhoods in Baltimore
um and the academic had an assumption
that if you could get them by I don't
know 15 then you can um you know move
them in the right direction okay
disabused him of this thought quite
quickly
Yeah by having him talk to some 15 year
olds it might have been even like 13 or
10 year olds uh and he's like well shoot
we just got to start earlier because
that that is a very wrong assumption
yeah well that's very interesting
um that's by the way a lot of people
have recommended the wire to me and I'm
often reluctant to take people's advice
about shows because typically it's like
oh man you got to see this it's so
amazing and uh you know it's about this
and this and this
what you've just said actually makes it
sound like something I would want to
watch
you know that that description of it to
me and it might not actually work for a
lot of people though but that
description of it is being sort of
almost like a narrative analysis of
these Interlocking Systems of power and
you know human development in its
opposite and moral choices
that makes for a good narrative I think
yeah it absolutely does and there's you
know there's lots of good action when it
needs to be but it's not the the focus
on you know if it makes narrative
um sense that it happens and if it
doesn't okay
so the the third one and I'd be
interested to get your take on this
because I think you're closer to this
than than I am the public and the
philosopher working together in a mutual
and reciprocal relation in order to deal
with issues that concern the community
so it's it's a form of cooperation with
and for the community and the re part of
the reason I I was saying I think that
you're a bit closer to that is
um because you've done more in the tech
and business world
and you know a lot of people are like oh
that's just about making money but no I
mean good Tech products and you know
good business organizations are aimed at
developing human potential and you know
making our lives better
um so I mean is do you do you see that
as like a a mode of public philosophy
then so you get a philosopher and
some sort of public and they've got to
work together so that means they've got
to be listening to each other right
hopefully
um unfortunately
um
lots of large tactic companies that have
had philosophers on staff have been
recently firing them yes
because there are saying hey we need to
slow down and yeah once again especially
if you're in a uh a publicly traded
company
um something that would potentially lose
you money in your next quarter real
reports
um is going to be against the will of
the major apparatus and the major point
of the organization itself and so
um a lot of times they'll talk a good
game like hey um you know uh what is it
I think it was Google's
um motto for a long time was don't be
evil right yeah they got rid of that and
so
hopefully there is
um a lot of times the interaction is
between companies and philosophers kind
of trying to take them down a peg
um and so uh I don't know there's a
philosopher and technologist
um out there called Jaron Lanier who's
um I think he actually coined the word
um virtual reality many years ago
um
and he he does a lot of those things and
you know and put it pointing out that
like data is the the new gold and uh
yeah
um companies are you know using that and
how
um what what is a an actual just way to
distribute the goods because right now
we as customers or users are giving up
that data for free right but that that
is the most valuable thing that we have
um and um this is an unjust transfer
um because the the amount of goods that
we get from the services that they
provide are so much less than the data
that we are providing and so
um he proposed a number of different
ways he could potentially build systems
that would allow for a more Justice
version of the the proceeds from those
uh Goods produced
so this I mean we're heading off in a
tangent here but this is actually
something I'd like to ask you about
um now granted none of us have like
total experience of the whole world of
business or anything like that so we're
not we're not generalizing from some
like perfect you know empirical
induction but
what's Your Gut sense is is it possible
and I don't I'm not just thinking about
philosophers but other Allied Fields
where
let's call them moral or ethical
questions and theories are playing an
important role so you mentioned you know
um the sort of myopic only focusing on
the next quarterly report attitude that
a lot of people in business have which
is not confined to the tech Spirits I
mean it's everywhere
um
what's Your Gut sense is it is it
possible for there to be sort of a
robust Incorporation
[Music]
of
we'll call it moral principles and and
decision making and action and like you
know looking you know sort of review
within a company
or is it should we say well that's
that's just not it's it'd be great if
that did happen it's just not going to
happen in point of fact because of the
ways in which
um the capitalist system you know
incentivizes things
um I mean do you think it's like you
know maybe if you're small you can do
that but if you get big it it becomes
impossible or no it's definitely not
possible and when it's it's we had lots
of companies in this country and around
the world that were beneficial to all
stakeholders and so uh what the the
biggest issue I see is that on what it
comes down to the bottom line yeah the
only stakeholders that are really uh
matter to most of these companies are
the investors yeah and so we have an
investor capitalist system that
removes all the other stakeholders as
valid on trade-offs okay to maximizing
profits for the and and returns
specifically for those investors and I
think we've already talked about on
incidification
right recently and that that is a you
know platform
um
uh capitalism you write these platforms
where you you insert yourself between
the user uh or the the user and the
provider the service are good
um and you lock them in and then you
um and then you once you have your
privileged position you squeeze both of
them you know you can all even see this
in Walmart I was just thinking that yeah
yeah that uh you know you have all you
have these low prices which get all the
companies to come in which kill off all
of your competition and you can
artificially reduce your prices as a
place in order to kill off physical
competition now everyone is stuccoing to
you and now that you have all the people
you can squeeze your producers to give
you cheaper and cheaper better and
better prices on the products that
they're selling and so because they have
that that middle point they are able to
squeeze everyone else it's like um hell
this all goes you can see this happen
even back in the uh
the oil days early like Rockefeller oh
yeah
yeah well he he owned all the refineries
yeah and so it didn't matter who the
supply or the the suppliers or the
buyers were everyone had to go through
him he had a monopoly on that and was
able to extract whatever prices or
um
uh purchasing prices that he you wanted
from either supplier or the purchaser
yeah and there's a there's actually a
great it's not about oil so much but
about grain um Frank Norris is the
octopus
uh great novel about that very Dynamic
and I remember I you know it's been a
long long I think I read it in high
school or something like that but I
remember this line in there where
there's this farmer and he's going to
the railroad people who transport the
Grain and he's saying uh I can't sell
you the grain at the price that you're
giving me you got to give me a better
price because I'm going to take a loss
on this and then I'm going to lose my
farm and you know the railroad guy who's
you know entire he's not just a railroad
guy it's a railroad shipping company
that then takes the Grain and does
everything with it he's like well we're
not giving you that price you have one
choice it's either our stuff or your
grain rots and so then the the farmer
blows up and he I forget exactly what he
asked but it's something along those how
do you get to do this what what is your
Criterion for setting a price and the
line that really has stuck with me is
the railroad guy says whatever the trash
traffic will bear so in other words
whatever we can get out of you what
whatever we can extract from you
um and that that does wind up being
an issue a lot of the time you know this
process of incidification is exactly
that right right
another thing I just want to add here
quickly is that you know you have seen
large companies like GE before
um was it Jack Welch took over in the
the 80s in which he you know the the it
was a uh a company where you could get a
good paying manufacturing job
um that would um from a strong company
and what half of everything built in
America seemed to come from GE at that
point in time yeah and he went through
and he
um
prioritized investor returns and the uh
you know entire stack ranking which is a
terrible for morale and on of the
individuals that yeah destroys you know
the cohesion of the workplace as well as
a whole bunch of other you know
processes that yeah
for short term really increase the the
investor return
um but where's ge now it is broken up
into three companies and uh many of the
the processes that you know once Jack
was gone
um have uh made the short-term gains
come to long-term losses yeah and pushed
off we talked about externalities
um that's costs that are borne by people
outside of like the the budgeting and
and the books and all that sort of stuff
I mean when when places have to close
when people lose their jobs there's all
sorts of what what they often call
knock-on effects that are borne by the
entire community
so so there are B corporations oh yeah
potential way but let's get to um you
know maybe uh what What's your proposal
well so I I
in the presentation I did I I proposed
something that we call pluralist meaning
that there isn't just one point of view
and I think this is it promotes like an
ongoing conversation about what public
philosophy is and and could be and so I
came up with six different main modes
and I might be wrong about this you know
that's part of being pluralist is saying
yeah somebody else maybe has some some
answers that I don't so I'm gonna just
rattle them off and then we can talk
about a few of them because we're we've
already used up a lot of the time so the
first is philosophy intended and carried
out in the public interest so this would
be you know op-ed pieces and important
forums or it could involve some activism
but the idea is that we're part of a
community and philosophy can contribute
to that the second is philosophy applied
within broader public or professional
context so for when for example when I
was asked out of the blue
by the Wisconsin paralegal Association
to talk at their annual conference about
ethics for continuing education stuff I
you know I was being asked as a expert
in ethics to come in and I had to like
look at well what are what are
paralegals actually concerned about it
was very eye-opening for me to find that
out so there's some some back and forth
applying it and then talking with people
I think that philosophers taking
philosophical arguments problems
positions and themes and
popularizing them that means you know
presenting them to the general public
like uh the philos history of philosophy
with no gaps I think that's a prime
example of that I think that's probably
what we do in in our show
um so that would be a third one and then
I think this is a really really
important one philosophy produced
provided and engaged in largely by
non-philosophers people who don't
identify as part of the academy they
might use the word philosopher to
describe themselves but think about the
stoic Fellowship the worldwide
organization a branch of which we have
here in Milwaukee most of the people
doing that are not academic philosophers
they're people who have an interest in
stoicism and then they study it and then
they talk about it and do things with it
so I think that's that's really
important and then Sophia the Society of
philosophers in America has this model
of philosophy side by side where you got
the professor National philosophers and
then you have the the other interested
people who are not academics and they're
working together and I think that's
that's an important kind of public
philosophy that we we want to have in
the picture and then I think there's a
sixth kind which is like what we're
doing right now engaging in meta
philosophy where which is philosophy
trying to figure out what the health
philosophy is in this case public
philosophy some of public philosophy
would be having discussions and perhaps
even debates about what public
philosophy is or what it should be doing
so
does that cover everything maybe not but
I think that this this covers it's a
a kind of boring presentation in part
because I think that's exactly what we
want you know it's not putting such a
heavy emphasis on like activism activism
could certainly fit in there the
importance of the community can
certainly fit in there but I think if we
think about what public what we count as
public philosophy and call public
philosophy it generally fits into those
six categories
I mean what what do you think I'm I'm
open to
uh criticism or suggestions is there
something you think is left out of that
or
um
in general I I they're good uh
priorities or principles here
um it's definitely as you said it's not
going to be a TED talk it's not going to
have that big like whole moment
um yeah
but I guess um I think you you kind of
uh hit something that uh with the
activism that um
maybe could be an extra point that is
more emphasis because you know we would
talk about Praxis which is applied
philosophy and
um
either you're doing that by yourself
like studying or trying to like inward
on yourself but you know going and doing
a some sort of public demonstration a a
protest is uh at least for many that
actually have a philosophical backing
for why they're doing these things is
Praxis supplied philosophy yeah and it
shows an ethical commitment right in a
in a way that's going Beyond just
posting things on Twitter putting
posters up or stuff like that actually
going out there and doing something okay
and unfortunately there you know there
are people with really negative
ideologies right that have you know
there there's
far right like you know fashion
organizations out there that are are
your proud boys type things where they
have a a they have a philosophy I don't
think it's good at all but they have
like a set of core ideals and they they
are putting it out there and using that
as the basis for why they are doing the
actions that they are doing yeah and if
you are not able to
um understand how they use their
rhetoric and how they use
um these
um corrupted World Views in order to uh
convince people to
um
do all sorts of things up to like Street
violence yeah then um then you're going
to have a hard time trying to combat
them because they a lot of times will
not
um engage in
um
correct rhetoric or what is um they're
they're not uh being
oh I'm honest intellect interlocutors
yeah good faith you could say this good
faith you know and and that brings up a
great point from uh that's made by uh CT
nagoy and his Manifesto for public
philosophy and he puts it like this in a
very earthy way if you don't have any
training and you go online looking for
philosophy you can actually understand
nine out of ten things are from the hate
web that he calls it
um and I I think there's a real
uh situation of appropriation think
about stoicism right there's all these
Bros out there who want to you know say
yeah we're gonna be stoics we're gonna
be tough guys and that basically means
like going around and beating people up
and taking cold showers and very far
away so what we need is people out there
saying no here's what what it really
looks like and so I think we're pretty
much at the end of our time and we have
another good quote to go out on by
somebody else
we leave you with the words of Michael
Sendel a public philosophy is an elusive
thing for it is constantly before our
eyes
foreign
[Music]